hallo liebe freundin begleiten euch zu
einem neuen video heute aus der bahn
mit matthias haller glaubt irgendwo
zwischen links bot man gerade in
bildreich durch die schnee verschneiten
strecken bundeswehr nicht überschwemmen
und ich dachte wir fangen mal an heute
mit dem thema unterschiede zwischen
deutschland etwa in der bahn generell
magst du anfangen
ja ich liebe bahn fahren also von olle
kampfmittel das diktat bitten mir auch
fetzig und straßenbahn fahren mal hott
bewegungsfreiheit manchmal aufstehen und
herumgehen wir haben dort lutherkirche
ist wir haben weiter und man kann in
ruhe arbeiten kann man ja im zug
konzentrierter arbeiten als irgendwo
anders und es so also autofahren ist
schon doof felder musste fahren ja du
bist ein wenig auskennt ja man kann auch
eigentlich nichts anderes machen
autofahren auch selbst als beifahrer
kann man nicht arbeiten oder irgendetwas
sinnvolles machen
klebt das auf einen kaffee und wasser
mache ich auch nicht super unbequem und
fliegen ist gut muss man machen wohin
muss er weiß es auch total unbequemsten
trotz viel bequemer wie fliegen fangen
an matthias mit den unterschieden
zwischen der bahn in deutschland und in
österreich als erster auf dem beispiel
dass diese flüge mit kraut hat jede
abteilung einen eigenen schaffner damit
nur erschaffen sondern auch gleichzeitig
essen verkauft und den müll einfach
sensationell etwas doch es gibt in
deutschland überhaupt nichts denn in
österreich in den anderen bahn das
eigentliche spezialität von der gewalt
waren die mikroben die öffentlichen
runde formen haben bisher immer das
würde ich mir auch für die bahn in
deutschland wünschen
klar jede partei hat einen kleinen
eigenen tier und auf eine person die für
tatsächliche bedrohung verkauft tickets
verkauft essen bringt kaffeetisch gibt
auch kunst und weiter erhöhen hat wenn
immer da und sagen normale immer für gut
guten schmäh auf die kleine entertainer
was mir aufgefallen bei euch gibt
raucher abteile ja ich persönlich bin
total happy weil ihn kaufen mit
betreuung brauche ich natürlich toll für
leute die kaufen gibt auch nur in der
privatbahn und nur einer teilen gibt bei
den 1100 bahn nicht neu wurde zu lange
abgeschafft jungen polen habe ich jetzt
gesehen wird einfach die toilette alte
abtei st
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir zu unseren liebling
bahngeschichte eine lieblingsgeschichte
die wir in der bahn erlebt hat ja eine
geschichte und war ich vorher immer von
wiener staatsoper meine familie zu
weihnachten um vor weihnachten an den
weihnachtsfeiertagen ist immer extrem
voll leute die sie überall auf den stoff
machen boden noch zu einer zweistündigen
flug fahrt komplett voller zurückkommend
als organ und schaffner folgten eine
durchsage treffpunkt arm wünschen ein
frohes weihnachtsfest genieße es in
vollen zügen und einen wunderschönen
passend aber und bekommt er das
sprachlich erklären sind es aber in
vollen zügen genießen sie zu fangen
aufdruck ein sprichwort vom etwas genau
noch stärker zu machen hat in vollen
zügen die ganz hingeben moment wird aber
gleichzeitig hofft natürlich auf der
follett auch wahnsinnig sie lustig durch
sein und gibt sogar website für die
besten waren durch kleidung und es gibt
aber auch welche leute die sich
beschweren da deutschland herrn ein land
der meckerer werden einige der besten
bahnsysteme der welt aber trotzdem denn
alle immer am lecken es gibt auch
hashtags und website wo die schönsten
berechtigen mitnehmen als wir begonnen
als österreicher fangeinrichtung und
raum bekannte was bist du denn und
rampen also fürs meckern will dass seine
würze aber hammam wird groß gewesen
österreich ist die eu weit die künstlich
besamt von sparten konzentrieren
es stimmt weil ich ins geschichte war da
bin ich neulich glaube von köln nach
berlin fahren
und irgendwann sagte der gartner
durchsage vom schaffner und der will
während gerade eine stunde in die
falsche richtung gefahren das hat
manchmal bringen wenn wir können nicht
auf der welt
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr eigentlich auch witzige
mann durch sein gefährt mein nächstes
thema anja natürlich engagiert und am
gewässer gefunden hast doch das setzte
castilla und war eine durchsage und war
der schaffner spricht mit megafon und
praktisch habe gute und schlechte
nachrichten schlecht von der lok sind
alle triebwerke ausgefallen gut wird den
job dann kein flugzeug waren ansage des
monats der zug des lokführers ist
aufgefallen er kommt jetzt mit dem taxi
wir bitten sie den zirkus zu
entschuldigen den wir gerade mit ihnen
veranstaltet haben die kollegen und
bistro geben wieder alles ich habe
vorhin ein stück kuchen gegessen und
würde ihm raten das auch zu tun
werbung schiffbruch ich weise darauf hin
dass unsere bremsen nicht funktionieren
meter halt dort wo wir ausgerollt sind
wir möchten das junge paar in vagen 33
darauf hinweisen dass die toiletten
leider nicht paarung geeignet das hat
einen personenzug ein güterzug im
güterzug ist es egal wenn die schweine
ihre beine oben haben hier nicht das
klingt ziemlich deutsch
das ist doch der rechte wird meine
technik und dem deutschen portal lacht
der ganze druck von müll und ehemänner
bitte nicht im zug zurück lassen vielen
dank reisende die sportlich unterwegs
sind und nicht zu viel gepäck haben
sollten den ganzen zug noch erreichen
man bremst mehrfach abrupt flugbegleiter
geht nach vorne
ich nehme mal die schnapsflasche weg das
klingt nach einer wahren geschichte
durch eine äußerst seltene verkettung
glücklicher umstände werden wir unser
ziel unerwartet plangemäß erreicht weil
50 leute an einer tür einsteigen
verzögert sich die abfahrt wir würden
diese dummheit zu entschuldigen
das ist aber typisch wie regen regen und
sehr gerne über die dummheit von anderen
menschen auf und sagen dass du auch
lauten sind zwar auch dort essen und
bonn würde gern mit carina und jana
schiedek ermitteln um die rund dalik
sandra kommerziell sei fortan matthias
des mieter und seiner mama
die holt uns nämlich vom flug ab und
werden direkt in die therme würde die
super league stimme mit wenn die therme
das wird ein spaß machen
hast du gerade die durch lange gehörte
ihr beifahrer aus mainz 05 und
organisatorischen missständen erreichen
wir heute gleich zwei aber willkommen in
salzburg meine heimatstadt und waren es
kommt sozusagen und zwar ist ein unesco
geschützte bahnhofgebäude diese
konstruktion und der bahnhof neu gebaut
worden und noch hat die ganze halle
profis abgetragen renoviert und neu
wieder hergibt und die neuen elemente
die modernen warum herumgebaut sehr
schön die wand frei hauptbahnhof so was
habt ihr noch nie gesehen lebt in den
säulen ist graffiti ja das zugverhalten
gewinn alter wirt kleine eisenbahnen
lassen sich bisher gesehen hat es von
der schönen seite hast du dich schon
gefilmt hatten
matthias gesagt ich finde vorstellen
dass du jetzt auch 30 wird und martina
körper ja ich freue mich auch voll
einverstanden ich frage mich was wir in
salzburg geht und wir haben wieder mal
nur der therme hören wollte ich gehe zu
hotels
ja das war unsere episode vom bahnfahren
heute aus der bahn in österreich gewinnt
jetzt mittlerweile angekommen salzburg
und wir wollen jetzt natürlich von euch
wissen was waren eure lieblings
bahngeschichte habt ihr was witziges
erlebt wie in deutschland unterwegs was
mögt ihr am bahn fahren und nötig
schreibt uns auf jeden fall auch
witzigen geschichten in unseren
kommentaren
ja und wir sind jetzt hier in waldburg
wunderschön witze aus matthias in deiner
heimatstadt herr wunderschönen 40 also
wir haben den besten spots gefunden
natürlich wollen wir euch zeitpunkt auch
noch in echt zeigen allerdings warten
wir damit bis das wetter etwas besser
ist bis zum sommer und im sommer machen
das ja endlich vor dem träume bekannte
teils eine leverage also ihre thermen
österreich werner lissy of the german
tour im letzten fall franck fangen wir
alle dialekte von otto bundesländern wir
wollen ganz österreich preisen im juni
ist es soweit wir haben uns endlich auf
einen termin geeinigt hat nur zwei jahre
gedauert aber ihr könnt euch mal drauf
freuen
dann werden wir euch intensiv österreich
vorstellen mit den verschiedenen orten
mit allen bergen und dialekten und genau
und wenn ihr noch lust habt übungen zu
sehen für unsere heutigen bahn episode
und übungen zu machen um euer deutsch zu
vergießen werdet unbedingt mitgliedstaat
schirm und dann erhaltet ihr neue boss
peter danke dir danke ich dem ausflug
wegen jetzt in die therme
[Musik]